[Musik]
wir haben festgestellt dass wir unsere
klimaschutzziele verfehlen obwohl wir
wahrscheinlich den teuersten klimaschutz
betreiben seit wir mit dem atomausstieg
der energiewende begonnen haben wir
haben im letzten jahr 27 milliarden euro
in die förderung erneuerbarer energien
gesteckt also grünem strom und trotzdem
eben unsere ziele verfehlt die 27
milliarden euro für den grünen strom
zahlen die mit der stromrechnung
überwiegend also wer soll ihn sonst
fallen wir zahlen ihnen über steuern und
wir zahlen ihnen über die stromrechnung
insofern müssen wir dringend überlegen
wie können wir das viele geld das wieder
reinstecken auch besser verwenden wir
brauchen ein neues system um zu den
klimaschutz ziel zu kommen
[Musik]
die co2 steuer würde auf heizstoffe und
kraftstoffe erhoben und diese verteuern
das bedeutet dass die bürger automatisch
anfangen an den stellen wo sie diese
heizstoffe oder kraftstoffe verwenden
sparsamer zu werden
die idee ist nicht ganz neu wir haben
vor 20 jahren schon zuschläge im rahmen
der ökosteuer auf benzin und heizöl
erhoben das hat allerdings nicht gewirkt
und deswegen machen wir auch ein
bisschen ein fragezeichen ob eine neue
form der co2 steuer besser wirkt denn
bei einer co2 steuer sind die bürger
natürlich frei zu entscheiden ob sie ein
bisschen mehr zahlen und dafür genauso
viel fahren wie vorher
dann ist aber für den klimaschutz nichts
gewonnen
[Musik]
aus meiner sicht ist der emissionshandel
das überlegenere modell vielleicht aber
in der politischen praxis schwerer
umzusetzen überlegen da ist der
emissionshandel deswegen weil die
politik da die möglichkeit hat einen co2
deckel festzulegen das heißt die
obergrenze des noch erlaubten co2
ausstoßes festzulegen und dann begibt
sie praktisch im diese menge in form von
zertifikaten an die wirtschaft und auf
diese weise entsteht ein co2 preis und
dieser co2 preis zeigt sich dann
natürlich in den produkten in der
wirtschaft im wohnen über all das ist
deswegen das überlegenere system weil
die politik eben die co2 menge begrenzen
kann und nicht darauf warten muss ob die
bürger wohl offene steuer so oder so
reagieren
das problem mit dem co2 emissionshandel
ist natürlich dass die politik wiederum
nicht so genau im griff hat wo dann sich
vielleicht auch verwerfungen auf tun
also wenn bestimmte industriezweige dann
durch den entstehenden preis vielleicht
nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig sind ist das
natürlich auch nicht im sinne eines
industrielandes wir müssen ja gucken
dass die wirtschaft im wettbewerb
besteht und zum beide muss man sagen zur
steuer und zum emissionshandel beides
ist nur sinnvoll wenn das ganze auch
europaweit am ende 1 geführt wird weil
sonst leidet die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
und die bürger können außerdem auch zum
teil ausweichen im grenznahen bereich
einfach im ausland tanken dann ist es
dann wieder günstig
also eine gewisse emotionalisierung ist
sicherlich wichtig um quasi auf ein
thema auf die bedeutung des themas
aufmerksam zu machen und ich finde es
auch einen sozusagen ein vorrecht der
jugend dass sie sich dass sie sich auch
aufregt und engagiert und denkt es müsse
alles schneller gehen
ich glaube auch was diese
demonstrationen verkennen ist dass es
unbedingt ein abgestimmtes vorgehen
braucht dass deutschland allein mit
seinem co2 ausstoß nur zwei prozent zum
welt co2 beiträgt das heißt wenn man in
deutschland den teuersten und den
ambitioniertesten klimaschutz macht der
erde ist nicht viel gewonnen das heißt
wir müssen zeigen dass wir einen
klimaschutz hinbekommen der bezahlbar
ist und zwar für viele länder und an der
stelle sind wir ziemlich schlecht und
ich glaube nicht dass uns hilft wenn die
grünen oder wenn der wenn die des future
bewegung jetzt einen dermaßen druck
macht dass wir unter umständen neue
gesetze machen die nur teuer sind aber
am ende nicht dazu führen dass andere
länder sagen das wollen wir auch so
machen und da ist glaube ich panik ein
schlechter ratgeber um gute gesetze
hinzubekommen
[Musik]
meine vermutung ist dass man doch wieder
die co2 steuer nimmt obwohl auch der die
wirtschaftsweisen also der der
ökonomische sachverständigenrat der die
bundesregierung berät gesagt hätte man
sollte das allenfalls übergangsweise tun
sondern und lieber den emissionshandel
der eben den deckel festsetzt einführen
ich meine vermutung ist dass wir dann
doch zur steuer greifen das haben wir
schon mal gemacht und dass man dann
sehen muss ob sie diesmal besser wirkt
als vor 20 jahren als rot grün das
versucht hat am ende wer aber nicht viel
gewonnen wenn wir immer höhere
steuersätze auf kraftstoffe heizstoffe
haben aber die leute sagen okay das
zahle ich einfach und dann bleibt kalt
für das klima nicht so viel nutzen übrig
[Musik]
[Applaus]